good afternoon Governor thank you thank
you very much for hosting me here now
arish I'm very grateful to president
alisi for having invited me to come to
Egypt and witness the humanitarian Aid
operations unfolding here in Alish and
at the Rafa border
crossing above all I want to thank the
Egyptian authorities you personally
governor for ensuring humanitarian
access to and from Gaza via
Rafa and for quickly setting up the Lish
Hub to stockpile vital
supplies Egypt is truly providing a
Lifeline to
Gaza and the European Union is making
full use of this Lifeline to address the
humanitarian needs in Gaza indeed we are
the largest donor to the Palestinian
people and one of the main and most
reliable donors to
un over the last month we have
quadrupled our humanitarian Aid to over
100 million
euro and in addition Our member states
have added 260 million
EUR we have organized a humanitarian
airbridge
operation it is bringing V supplies to
Alish for the people of Gaza we have
today completed 15 flights so far and we
are organizing more and more flights
every day none of this would be possible
without the excellent and close
cooperation with the Egyptian
authorities with un and the Egyptian red
crescent this is why we have have
established a coordination cell with the
International Federation of the red
crescent and the Red
Cross and I'm happy to be able to hand
over to the Egyptian red Crest in the
most recent Aid donated by the European
Union of course we all agree that the
volume of Aid reaching Gaza need to
increase this is the idea of behind the
proposal from for example also Cyprus to
set up a maritime Corridor we are in
very close contact with the Cyd
authorities to support them in defining
the logistical parameters of such a
corridor and we stand ready to provide
technical expertise in all relevant
Fields based on their
needs we are also supporting Egypt as it
helps wounded Palestinians for example
with medical equipment like anesthesia
machines from Sweden or ventilators
oxygen concentrators ultrasound machines
from our European Union emergency
Reserve that is based in Germany in
Hungary and in the
Netherlands in addition to our
humanitarian support we're reaching out
to our partners in the region to prevent
violence from spreading
I had a very good meeting on this with
President adissi this morning we
discussed in
particular how to work together to avoid
Regional
escalation Egypt is a key partner in
this its voice is heard across the
region and by all
sectors tomorrow I will be in Jordan to
we meet with King
abdalah Jordan also has an important
stabilizing role in the Middle East and
the king is steadfast in his search for
lasting solution to the
conflict my discussions go hand in hand
with those of the hivp Joseph Bell who
is also engaging actively with its
counterparts in the reg because dialogue
is so essential to keep the flame of
Peace alive
and this brings me to my final
Point even as we deal with the urgency
of
today we must also think about what the
day after could look like and how
Israelis and Palestinians can regain
hope have a
perspective and for this they need a
political solution and this Horizon is
the two-state
solution we requires the agreement
between Israelis and
Palestinians but the European Union is
ready to support this process once the
time comes in very close cooperation
with our friends and partners thank you
so much thank you again thank you again
governor